becky is on the line in florida hi Becky
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
how can Rachel me help okay the future
is kind of scary to me because I didn't
take your course until a couple years
ago and then I didn't really apply it my
husband and I are both retired and so we
don't have a lot in savings and we're
both on Social Security which is not
much and the future is just scary to me
but I was wondering if now is a good
time we only had this one shot to put
14,000 in a Roth IRA because of our age
and my husband retired last June so we
had this one shot to put 14,000 in a
Roth IRA we don't have that much in
savings but everything's paid for it's
just I know how fast money is going to
go because we don't make that much and
Social Security because he was
self-employed so he had an earned income
last year yes until June okay then you
can for before your tax filing date this
year you can do it the Roth 414 you're
correct about that how much money do you
have in savings we have a hundred
thousand in the bank and eight thousand
in savings okay and no money saved for
retirement whatsoever no no way to get a
small pension okay seen the pension and
the two social security checks can you
live on that every month it it's gonna
be really tight yeah you're gonna have
to because the hundred thousands like
the last ten minutes otherwise I know
got to adjust out go or your income one
of the two so do you have car payments
no everything the house is paid for
there's no payments no charge cards when
I reach or something I pay it off at the
end of the month
to get a debit card and you and your
husband need to get on a budget that you
agreed to where you are maintaining your
life without touching that hundred
because even if you burn through it at
$1,000 a month it's going to go away in
a hundred months which is yeah yeah I
don't know that's what's scaring me so
how healthy are you to what age are you
I'm 66 and my husband's 70 how's your
health my health is good I nobody else I
have to I have Sjogren's which is an
autoimmune disease and he has heart
issues but he what could you all do to
earn some money once the crisis is over
I don't want you out there running
around with those things going on right
now but once this is behind us what
could you do to create some income well
he could he could probably Drive a
couple of days a week he was he did on a
dump truck so he could drive for
somebody a couple of days a week
I can drive every day a week he had to
eat but I think he could but he's he's
tired and he's yeah yeah he's 70 so he's
just okay well I mean you guys got to
take care of yourselves I don't want you
to do something a minute might be that
you find out a business idea that you
could start that doesn't make you tired
that you could make more money I don't
care what it is but you've got an income
issue and you cannot tear into the
savings if you're not going to tear into
the savings because you've solved your
income issue meaning you're gonna make
more and or budget to live on what you
have coming in then yes I would do the
Roth if you're going to burn through the
budget it's not going to serve any
purpose because you're going to burn
through it too and so don't do the
14,000 in the wrong unless you're going
to get your budget balanced if you can
learn to live on the Social Security in
the pension plus whatever you can earn I
think you might be able to you don't
have a single debt in the world then I
would go ahead and do the wrong yeah and
I would say to Becky that it's you guys
it sounds like you haven't done a budget
you said like yeah it's gonna be really
really tight if you just live on the
pension and what you're getting
Social Security but maybe you guys do
the budget and you realize oh wow we
can't cut kind of here and there and
live on this and maybe you just work one
day a week and I don't have to be a ton
to bring in something would that be
something more creative than just
driving for sure that makes more money
for sure that's the other thing they're
not to be strenuous to make money
necessarily so lots of people find
really interesting things to do at 65
and 70 years old that make more than
they used to make yeah you don't dump
truck driver you know yeah I think so I
would be thinking about that now again I
don't want you guys out there running
around right now
you're definitely medically what they're
describing is that higher risk and I
don't I wouldn't want you to do that
today but but as soon as this clears and
you're safe I would think about that and
I would do the Roth because you've got
to balance this budget you don't have a
choice you've got to balance it because
you're gonna burn through it if you
don't learn to live on a plan you and
your husband agreeing to every month
that is within your income you you you
can't very few people have enough
savings to not do that if you had two
million dollars you might make it but
you're not gonna make it with ninety
thousand bucks and so hey thank you for
the call